[Music]
hello good evening how are you now it
will be tired by the end of the day so
we are excited to participate in this
conference with so many nice talks and
our presentation will be related to the
Big Data Platform for cross media
monitoring and my name is Liana
I'm data scientist and my colleague John
Carlos his digital product manager we
are working in Eureka which is
Technology Center in Catalunya and yes
so now we will present you our journey
in developing this this platform so this
is the agenda of this presentation we
will start from from the context from
the motivation where we explain why do
we think that our platform is innovative
and then we will move to to to
presenting the platform itself starting
from the generic concept and then going
to the more technical details like
architecture and specific challenges
that that we solved so first of all
regarding the context so online social
media networks have become fundamental
places in in modern societies for
discussing the content of different
topics right so millions of people share
the their opinions about different
products services events in in social
networks and also they review the
opinions of other people in social
networks and of course of course this it
is quite logical that marketing
specialists
have have a lot of interest in in social
media monitoring platforms that allow
collecting this digital footprint and
enrich this digital footprint with other
media sources like for example online
news or blogs forums and so the main
objective of marketing specialists is to
understand for example well to analyze
the progress of the advertisement
campaign or for example to reveal the
influencer in the community in order to
spread the messages through this
influencer and there might be many many
other objectives that the marketing
specialists can have when using these
platforms so here you can see the
examples of the classical social media
monitoring platforms so basically these
platforms apply quantitative analysis
techniques okay in order to answer the
questions like you can here you can see
here some examples of such questions for
example which is the user the users
attitude toward some particular product
or brand or another example is what is
the number of users who have mentioned
particular brand on Facebook yeah so
these are the questions like what or
which type of questions and normally the
content analysis techniques and also the
text mining natural language processing
techniques are used right so here you
can see a typical example like this kind
of platforms provide the dashboards with
the outputs with the summary outputs of
the quantitative analysis and these
outputs are
memorized in the form of pictures or
line plots bar plots even maps yeah
so this there's boards look very nice
but what happen happens if we want to if
we want to dive a little bit deeper yes
so and normally marketing specialists
want to dive deeper so they want to make
the qualitative analysis not only
quantitative but also qualitative
analysis in order to answer the
questions like how and why yeah and now
we will show you some examples in order
to justify to clearly explain you why
the qualitative analysis is so important
for social media networks monitoring
okay thank you Liana and good evening to
all of you a well from the business
point of view I want to share with you a
question there is anyone here from the
telco industry or mobile manufacturers
not okay it is not personal with this
with this band as commented by my Liana
we are a technology transfer company
okay we are similar to do from Hoover in
Germany and what we try to solve when a
company searches in new racket the
solution to a business need okay we
share it our applied research platform
okay that is called kalium during this
event that we are very proud of hosting
here in in Barcelona for the last five
years that is the Mobile World Congress
so in 2015 we perform at a
proof-of-concept OK'd of this technology
to to see if this bill from the
specifically in the social media
analysis
could bring more powerful tools for
example to community managers and people
that is specialized in in in marketing
okay so we show at our conclusions to a
communication agency okay so we perform
it an analysis one day of about the
impacts of CTE in the in the in the
social media when they present this new
model okay when we perform this
quantitative analysis we can see that
city was very very good in position in
this this announcement okay but if we go
deeper and and see what is the insights
that brings our analysis okay you have
to think about these analysis from the
works of an Alan Turing okay in this
field of graph networks and then you can
see that for example this city community
okay when we want to to research these
interactions between users and try to
find some patterns around a community
okay that's why we are explaining that
we focus on these graph networks
analysis we see that these users are
only interacting with a small community
are on specifically with city okay so
it's strange that they don't interact
with other hashtags or with other users
like Mobile World Congress and so as a
company you could use this kind of
technologies from for brand reputation
and for your campaigns as influential
marketing but you see that with what
this technology we try to
to go deeper in in searching this kind
of boat users and so on and in a very
visual way so as you see several they
serve all Twitter suspended these
accounts that are BOTS okay so four
asses are specifically competitive tool
to to perform this analysis and also
what happens when when when these
Community Managers or you could want to
analyze from these media channels your
messages when you talk about vital
messages and and so on so we perform
also a new visualization that our
dashboard permits for example to
showcase that around the community how
these messages are getting viral not in
real time but nearly real-time okay
because we are coming from from a proof
of concept in 2015 so we are here in
2018 so the main challenges was to scale
the initial platform and also to do this
kind of visualizations so mainly also we
are very proud that our technology
supports when a very big volumes of data
around not only social media so also in
in online forums newspapers and also we
collaborate with another communication
agency that provides new sources of
information that are newspapers physical
newspapers television and radio so that
company that wants to to see if they are
having impact in different media sources
we can cross this this media and obtain
so
Dino be solid stations as the one we are
showing now so Liana will talk about
specifically technical approach of the
of the platform yeah so in the previous
slide you have seen just some part of of
the front end of our of our platform so
by the way the platform is called Kali
oh yes and it's it's actually explained
in this slide so let's put it on the
y-axis so basically our platform
combines quantitative and qualitative
analysis techniques and we suppose that
this is one of the strong points of this
platform so basically we are able to
answer not only the questions what of
what type but also how and why for
example not only understand what kind of
topics are popular and in particular
community but also try to ask the
question why these topics are so popular
yeah and there might be many other
questions that the analyst that works
with the front-end can ask to this
front-end and try to find the answer
yeah so kalium applies the network
analysis techniques in order to support
the qualitative analysis yes so these
are basically graph algorithms so what
we do we represent social network is a
huge graph and then we apply graph
algorithms in order to retrieve the
knowledge from them from from from these
networks yeah and you may ask the
question okay but why don't you use the
existing graph analytics tools like for
example Gaffey or Stanford network
analysis platform or any other platform
that currently exists and well our
measure motivation is that for example
if we take gave you which is very very
popular very nice tool and if we have
we take also snip so they have one
limitation they can work with large
networks but in terms of scalability
they are limited so they can scale on a
single big memory machine yeah so they
do not work these tools do not work in
the distributed environment and in case
of gallium basically what we do we
develop the distributed versions of
graph algorithms or we use the
distributed versions of existing graph
algorithms for example from the SPARC
graphics library and so one of the
advantages is the scalability next we
also simplify the visualization of huge
graphs how so basically we represent
graphs hierarchically and later on I
will show you how exactly and including
also video generation that can
demonstrate for example the community
creation over time and the final the
final advantage is that our platform
allows the customized generation of the
graph and in this case the marketers the
the marketing specialists can customize
can parameterize the graph generation
process according to the particular
objectives of of the marketing analysis
and here on this slide you can see the
generic concept so until now we do not
talk about particular technologies but
we will do it in the next slides so
first of all I would like to explain the
generic concept here you can see how
kalium can be integrated into the
existing infrastructure of the client
company so basically this is the real
example and let me let me comment you
this example so in this case the client
company fair
so different data sources for the raw
data the data sources for the raw data
so basically the data comes from Twitter
from Facebook from online news blogs
forums etc etc all this data is
pre-processed yes and then it is stored
in in the databases in this particular
case in elasticsearch and besides this
part there is also some process that
periodically for instance once per day
executes or sends the request to our
platform and this request triggers the
graph generation process and when the
graph generation process is finished the
marketing specialist can visualize this
graph in the front-end yeah so basically
our platform column expects the query
the input query into JSON format which
comes from from from the software of the
client and through the rabbit mq and
this query as I said triggers the graph
generation process and the calculation
of all the metrics that that are needed
so since this is the data engineering
conference I would like to briefly
explain you the data that we work with
so we splitted this present explanation
in four dimensions data volume data
format data diversity and velocity so in
case of data volume basically our
platform can work with millions of
Records nodes and age and finally it
depends on the cluster setup and then in
case of data format currently we have
the data
nectar that retrieves the raw data from
elasticsearch but we are working on the
development of other data connectors in
case of data diversity we receive as you
may see in the previous slide we work
with the data from Twitter from Facebook
from blogs forums online news and other
social media so the diversity is quite
huge and then in case of data velocity
well our platform does not work with the
streaming data so we are working with
with batch data basically we receive the
the queries for example once per day for
particular client and this query lunch
or triggers the full algorithmic process
in in in in spark
ok the next and here you can see the
four different challenges that we had to
solve in order to develop our platform
the first challenge the challenge number
one is so how to flexibly create new
graphs that better fit the goals of
particular marketing campaign yes so
here the objective was to provide the
flexibility to marketers about the
creation and the analysis of graphs for
any objective of the marketing analysis
here the next challenge was how to scale
the graph mining algorithms because many
algorithms are well just developed for a
single machine they do not have any
distributed version so we had to solve
this problem in this challenge and then
the next the third the first challenge
was how to persist the large graphs so
we had to select a particular database
for storing our graphs and the final
challenge was how to visualize large
complex
graphs because imagine if you want to
visualize billions of nodes on a single
screen probably it does not make any
meaning any sense for the analyst right
so well maybe to have the global picture
here but if you want to make the more
detailed and analysis you must provide
some specific visualization tools for
this and we solve this challenge also so
now we will go through each of these
challenge step by step and I will show
you the examples how how exactly we
solve them so the first one how do we
create our graphs so take a look at this
well maybe I don't know if you can see
very well but take a look at this JSON
query so this is the JSON query that we
receive in Rabbit MQ and this query
specifies in details how the nodes and
age of the social network should be
created and currently we have three
types of routes explicit rule implicit
rule and cluster rule implicit rule I
will give you an example implicit rule
might be for example let's consider the
original Twitter that was retweeted by
other person so in this case this is
implicit true explicit rule sorry and
the source node is the original Twitter
tweet and the target node is the the the
person the user who retweeted this to it
and there is the edge between them so
this type of relation we specify with
with explicit rule the next one implicit
rule it's a little bit more tricky it's
to reveal to construct the hidden age
let's say for example let's imagine some
tweets that have the links to some
publications yeah to some posts so in
this case the source node will be the
tweet the original tweet and
the target note will be this publication
that is reference inside the tweet this
is the example of implicit rule and the
final one the cluster rule for creating
the ages of the graphs basically in this
case the nodes that are connected by by
by the age must have some similar
characteristic for example this must be
the publication's on the same domain or
this must be the publication's related
to the same topic or whatever so and
very important part I just want to
highlight it very once again
so these rules are specified by
marketing specialists so marketing
specialist say how do they want to
create the graph yeah and this is one of
the strong part of our platform yeah so
here you can see what happens actually
with this input query as I said before
this input query specifies how nodes and
H sub work of the graph should be
created once we we have the graph
created we apply graph algorithms to
talk to this graph right and finally
this graph algorithms allow us revealing
different hidden interactions hidden
patterns or understand for example more
about the diffusion of the content
inside inside the community over time
and etc the second challenge was to
solve the scalability issue of the graph
mining algorithms so currently we have
three groups of the algorithms the first
one is the detection of communities then
ranking of nodes and the definition of
the roles of the nodes in case of the
detection of communities we use Leuven
algorithm and in this case we were happy
because luanne algorithm is available
in graphics so we were we are using this
existing version of Louvain algorithm
with some small changed but generally we
use this one and so this Leuven
algorithm works based on the
neighborhood every stick so it it is the
iterative algorithm and on each
iteration it tries to improve the metric
which is called modularity and this
iterative process continues until the
modularity cannot be optimized more then
the process stops and then at this
moment all the communities are specified
so what do we understand by communities
so basically we assign each user or each
node in the in the graph to the
community yeah and then we can see
different clusters ranking of nodes
currently we're using hits algorithm and
hits algorithm this is the hyper link
induced topic search algorithm it's
quite old but there were there were no
distributed version existing in the
market so we had to develop our own code
in SPARC and Scala for this algorithm
and it is openly available in in get
inget lab in github sorry so this
algorithm calculates all thora T's and
hubs for each node so basically the
higher is the outside symmetric the more
out coming age has the node and the more
the higher is the hub metric then the
higher is the number of incoming H in
the node and we are also currently
thinking about the implementation of the
PageRank and maybe other ranking
algorithms that might be useful in the
final one
is the specification of the roles of
each note we use the algorithm from the
scientific paper of Kimura this is from
mmv
this is quite famous scientific paper so
basically we implemented again we
implemented the distributed version of
the algorithms proposed by by Kimura and
these algorithms work with with two
different metrics which are within
module degree and participation
coefficient so based on these two
metrics we can assign a row to each node
for example we can say if this if this
is the ultra peripheral node or this is
peripheral node and then the marketing
specialist can interpret the
significance of the role next so the
next challenge was the selection of the
database for storing the graphs so we
were thinking between these four options
now for J elasticsearch jános graph and
oriented be our final choice was to
select orange EB and I will explain why
we were also quite strongly thinking
about about now for J but in case of
neo4j there are problems with with
sharding and well there are some tricks
to solve the sir at the sharding issue
but in case of orion TV it is easier
also orion DB is the multi multi modal
database which means that it supports
the native graph storage and also if
it's necessary to store any other type
of data it is possible to do and one
more interesting advantage of orange eb
is that it supports sql-like queries yes
so the learning curve is quite short
and yeah because in order to make the
queries - in order to make the graph
queries to Orion DB we can use just a
graph like a service SQL like language
and and that's it and yeah and also the
license is a patch version 2 which means
that for commercial projects there is no
problem to use to use Orion DB so
basically this was the major reason why
a reason why we selected Orion GB next
one and the final challenge that we
solved was how to visualize huge graphs
basically we have the hierarchy like
different levels so we we split our
graph into the different levels the
first level is the graph of communities
it's it's the highest level yeah the
graph of communities where each node is
the community of users then if the
marketing specialist wants to go deeper
then he can select several communities
or particular community of the interest
and then go inside this community and
observe the graph of users that
constitute these communities and also it
is possible to see to see the contents
the contents they say the publications
that users are sharing or reviewing in
this particular in this particular
community next yeah so for each for each
type of node for community or user or
content here you do not see the content
here you can see only communities and
users we have a long list of metrics
we put it here just some examples of the
matrix but in general our platform
calculates more matrix for example for
each user it calculates the audience the
hub the authority the role the
engagement rate which community does it
belong to and etcetera etcetera etcetera
and we are working on extending this
list of metrics and for each community
it calculates the average Authority the
average hub total audience etc also when
when the community was created the start
and end date so yeah so a wide range of
different of different metrics that are
very useful for marketing specialists
and here on this slide you can you can
see now the more detailed architecture
of our platform so input queries that
you have seen before which are basically
JSON strings they are sent by by the
customer by the client to the rabbit MQ
and we receive actually these queries in
the rabbitmq and then we have Scala back
end okay and we use a patch levee rest
service how many people of you have used
a patch living oh okay yes so we're
using capatch living in order to execute
spark jobs on demand yeah so every time
we receive a new query we parse this
query and we send the request to a patch
live server in order to execute our
graph algorithms in spark yeah so then
the spark program connects to elastic
search where we have
the raw data about well the rotate about
the publications in Facebook Twitter
blogs forums etc etc so all the raw data
then the spark program gets this data
from elasticsearch and applies the rules
from the input query like implicit
explicit and cluster rule in order to
construct the nodes and age of the graph
yeah
so then after this this spark program
applies Leuven algorithm heats algorithm
and rows detection algorithm and also
some formulas to calculate the matrix
for example engagement rate metric and
other metrics and when all this
calculation process is finished after
this we save the graph together with all
the metrics in Orion DB and also we send
the notification to the API and when so
saying like hey the the graph generation
process is finished the analyst can
start reviewing or working with the
graph so once this process is finished
the graph can be visualized in the
front-end and previously at the
beginning of this presentation you have
seen some small examples and the front
end has different filters okay so
because again the idea is to not show
the full graph on the screen but we
provide a tool kit consisting of many
different filters that the user can use
for example very simple filter to define
the start and eighth and end date for
for for for the age yeah because we have
time stamps assigned to all aged or for
example we can put another filter like
maximally I want to see up to hundred
communities
or I want to see just the users that
have the top 10 users that have the
largest values of authority or largest
values of hub yep and then in this way
the marketing specialists can work with
the front end and can communicate with
the front end like some kind of what-if
analysis can ask different questions to
the front end and retrieve the knowledge
yeah and basically we have almost
finished the presentation so this is the
clusters tab so our current cluster is
quite small and it consists of the
following components so we have the
spark cluster this / cluster consists of
three nodes we developed we developed
spark cluster using Campari and embodies
such a nice tool that even data
scientists can create the cluster
without any problem so this is my
example actually i'm data scientist and
i use somebody to try to create the
cluster and really it takes just a
couple of hours to to create the spark
cluster so you can see the parameters of
each instance these parameters are not
so impressive probably but well as I
said our cluster is currently quite
small then we have the two instances
dedicated to the Orion GB we have one
control instance and we have one
instance for front-end and for the API
of front-end and yes so this cluster is
used mainly for testing and validation
process and currently it's more than
enough for us yeah but of course
obviously we can we can add more
resources if it is necessary and yeah
one more thing that I wanted to say so
this cluster is built in OpenStack and
the final thing well of course this was
not
the work office of a single person or
for two persons so we worked in a team
and this these are people of different
profiles who participated in the project
starting from the research idea because
initially it was research idea so Pablo
whose data scientists in Eureka so
basically this kalyan product was his
initial research idea then we have also
software engineer - software engineers
who also worked in this in this project
and yes so if you have any questions if
you have any proposals you are welcome
to contact us here you have the contact
details for the Barcelona headquarter of
of Eureka you have our our telephone
number our email so you're welcome to to
contact with us and with any question or
proposal thank you for your attention
hello when you were selecting the graph
database and you check the performance
of the different options and especially
how was between Oren DB and neo4j yeah
so basically we we were making this
analysis together with with the with the
client we with the client with a current
client of this of this platform and we
analyzed in details the documentation
and also we considered the previous
experience regarding for example now for
J in other projects and as I said before
our main main motivation for selecting
the Orion GB was basically related to
sharding yeah because now for J does not
support it so natively and also we
wanted to have some multi model
database and neo4j is just it can serve
only for storing graphs it's not Multi
multi modal database it's just the
native graph storage system right and
also there is one more parameter that we
considered which does not really relate
to the performance but it was important
for us it's the question of the license
so in case of Nell for J there are some
limitations for commercial usage but in
case of orange EB there is no problem
and finally the language that is
supported to make the queries to the
graph so in case of for ng b this is SQL
SQL like language so yeah so and then as
I said based on previous experience of
our customers with neo4j and jános graph
so finally we came to the conclusions to
use orange eb but coming back to your
question if we made the detailed like
performance analysis like with with the
numbers for the same input data like
let's try to save to save the data in
Nell for gene Janos grunting Orion GP
then no this kind of detailed analysis
numeric analysis we have not done but we
made our decisions based based on other
parameters that I said
the other thank you for your talking can
you open the slide with the architecture
yeah when you were talking about the
front and you said that the marketing
specialist can apply some kind of
filters so can you explain where the
filter is accepted on the front end
level or maybe in the Hadoop cluster
where okay I will try to answer this
question I was not working on the front
end but I will try to answer this
question so basically you can see that
the front end community well has the API
right and the component that merged the
spark part with the front end is Orion
GB right so Orion GB it's like yeah like
like the bridge between between spark
and the front end so we have API that
each time the user specifies some
filters in this case the API sends the
request to Orion GB and returns the data
so we have all the data for particular
input query pre-saved pre-processed yeah
but it's huge amount of data and then
the marketing specialist can can
retrieve some sub parts of the graph can
make different queries based on filters
yes the filter quests as longer to
execute than the origin request oh it
doesn't matter
the new request well when we accept new
filter is it
does it take a longer time to execute
than the origin request well it takes a
little bit longer time but from the user
final user perspective it's I mean maybe
it can take up to two seconds to wait
for some particular complex query but we
are not talking about one minute or five
minutes so okay thank you
you